[Music]  in eight on your side now after some  frustration of delayed christmas  packages last holiday season the u.s  post office really stepped up its game  made some changes to smooth the process  out like hiring more workers increasing  transportation and obtaining new robotic  machines  we actually have added 112 new  processing machines throughout the  country they can process up to 3200  packages per hour so that's roughly 25  thousand packages in an eight hour shift  even with the best late plans there's  always a possibility of a wrench in the  system this year's unknown comes with  anything that is shipped from overseas  and then delivered by the post office  but usps says once your mail is in its  hands workers will do their best to make  sure it does arrive on time